are you and the Prime Minister divided
one of the shortest serving home
secretaries in history never a happy
relationship with her prime minister
with the Prime Minister split on
migration Boat Crossings and student
visas oh Liz is going to be brilliant
she's going to give us a a boost once a
leadership hopeful many think still a
leadership hopeful getting herself
noticed with no hold barred language
likely to appeal to toy traditionalists
it's the guardian reading
tofu eating
dare I say the anti-growth Coalition
that we have to thank for the disruption
that we are seeing on our roads today in
fact after being caught transferring
sensitive government documents to her
private phone for sharing with
colleagues she may be gone but her
allies in government now towing a
difficult line the reality is I'm Bound
by the ministerial code to represent
government policy now we have to be
realistic about migration Sue Ella was
taking a good strong line on the boats
Crossing illegally that's still got to
be dealt with and suello was taking a
good pragmatic line on the seasonal
agricultural workers scheme which again
I support and also of course we stood on
a Manifesto commitment but it's not for
me to preempt what the prime minister's
migration policy is the two most senior
members of her cabinet gone five days
apart doesn't suggest stability means
loyalists reaching forever more unusual
arguments to justify what's been going
on I have heard reports that there were
people in the Bank of England and in the
treasury who were not fully supportive
or compliant of the chancellor in his
policy you repeat these reports you
believe these extraordinary reports
which some would claim is a conspiracy
theory I'm just saying that not
everybody in the Bank of England and the
treasury were in my view sufficiently
supportive of the chancellor profound
political differences inside the
conservative party turned later in the
day to personal confrontations as
tempers frayed and allegations of
shoving were made in what was a perfect
metaphor for today there was an
allegation of bullying in the government
division lobbies made by a senior labor
MP there was a group including several
cabinet ministers who were basically
shouting at them and and at least one
member was physically pulled through the
door into the voting Lobby now that is
completely out of order in our system we
are meant to be able to vote without
fear or favor he was to my mind
physically manhandled into the into the
lobby and before that there was a whole
load of doing like this very aggressive
I've never I've been an MP for 21 years
I've never seen that
he says this picture is supporting
evidence for his claims Jacob Reese mogg
visible in this photo vehemently denied
that there was shouting pushing or
manhandling whether it's the personal
political or on policy for conservatives
in Parliament there's a growing
perception it's going to be all but
impossible to put it back together again
how many will even try samcoat Sky News
Westminster